in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Andrew
and Sarah are with us hey guys how are
you welcome you guys were you from
Dripping Springs Texas and what is
Dripping Springs near just outside of
Austin okay very weird
I'm sorry west of weird west of weird
yeah Austin's cutting that down pretty
solid I love it
very cool so you guys are here to do
your debt free scream yes sir all the
way to Nashville yes sir how much of you
guys paid off one hundred and fifty
three thousand four hundred forty three
dollars and seventeen cents I love it
very well done and how long did that
take forty two months almost near a your
range of income during that time starter
at about 85 and this year we'll be at
about 180
okay Wow big income what do you guys do
for a living he's a realtor furler and I
do I work in cytogenetics
and I also I'm a massage therapist as
well on the side for extra income okay
so the real estate business is booming
and so is genetics yes sir absolutely so
right after we started our debt snowball
actually saw you at entree leadership
one day in Austin and I was fortunate
enough I can't remember who was the
emcee that day but during one of the
intermissions I had written a note that
I wanted to hand to you I figured I'd
give it to the emcee and it was at
Riverbend Church which I went to in
college so I knew I knew the facility
pretty well and when it ended I couldn't
find the emcee anywhere but I was on
stage and you were about five steps away
from me standing by yourself so I'm like
oh well here's who I wanted to have it
anyway so here you go cool and I can
honestly say that that even though it's
just the one-day version that I don't
think I'd be running my business today
if it weren't for that Wow and the
moment the majority of that income
increase is from real estate good for
you well congratulations man I'm proud
of you I'm glad we could help
thank you I for some reason I think I
remember that happening I mean because
that's a cool stage it's a different
vibe in that venue than most of the
stage
we're on yeah very much so that's kind
of the stages down low and the seats go
up and and you know it's really
accessible yes very cool well it's good
to meet you again well thanks for being
here you guys what kind of death was the
hundred and fifty three thousand UT
almost all of it with student loans a
little over a hundred and thirty
thousand University of Texas yes sir our
hukum Hornet I guess is appropriate yeah
okay way to go you guys and your degrees
are in what why I studied biology at UT
and then I went and I studied a year at
MD Anderson which I know you're familiar
oh I know you very well Dave yeah and I
have a BS in biochemistry that I'm using
very well today and we well the math
anyway yeah and we met there at UT okay
you're very cool so tell me what
happened forty-two months ago that put
you on this radical journey to pay off
the student loan that's so freakin fast
so the story really goes back about five
years ago when we right before we got
married we were normal we bought a house
we had two hundred thousand dollars in
debt
most of it still student loans but one
of the big three banks was sure here you
go here's a two hundred thousand dollar
mortgage just seems like a great idea
yeah and making those payments not
seeing in the needle move it just got
really sick and tired and we finally had
our just enough is enough moment and
I've been wanting to go into real estate
for a while there was an opportunity
that came up with my prior employer
where the transition happened a little
quicker than we were anticipating but it
was just a perfect opportunity and we
jumped on it so that 36 month or the
three and a half years 42 months is
really right about after I started in
real estate also well we're down to now
so where'd y'all get connected to us
along that journey Sara introduced me to
you when pretty shortly after we'd met
and we you know kind of sort of followed
the medicine exactly yeah we picked and
chose and more yeah exactly now we we
drank the kool-aid a if our son is named
after you so
well his name is Carter Ramsey oh my
gosh
yeah after your family because of what
that just that the values are your
family teaches well I'm blown away okay
so that happened you got serious 42
months ago and then decided to pick the
Dave stuff back up or tell me how about
we decided to pick it up and just draw a
line in the sand and that was the day
that we put it all up on the kitchen
fridge and got the red sharpie out and
every single time we'd pay one off we'd
go over there and cross it out and get a
little more excited I'm not gonna lie
those last few debts were really really
big and started getting slower and so a
while but having having Carter because
you always want your child to be better
than what you are in all aspects mm-hmm
and so he's gonna have a head start yeah
how old is 20 months so halfway through
this process yes sir that just adds more
fuel to the fire what you're saying
maybe it's like yeah this is serious I
gotta be an adult now it helps to be I
mean it's great for us as it we're a
team you know while she was pregnant we
added additional fuel to the fire we
started coordinating FPU oh wow two of
them now we're setting up the third one
right now well thank you thanks for
doing this happy to do it but there's
nothing like teaching it to make you do
it
absolutely yeah that really really
rekindled the fire and so on top of cash
flowing him through it one thing I will
say kind of kind of sort of stupid tax
in my opinion we refinanced about three
months before we really started the debt
snowball up so we also paid $55,000 of
our mortgage off in that time oh my god
so we would have been here sooner
yeah we refinance on an 11 year okay
whoa yeah really tight okay that's
amazing guys way to go yeah you gotta
feel great we do so what was the hardest
part of the journey
hmm I don't know I don't really I mean I
I thought I mean we've we've just been
consolidating forgotten I think
communicating it with our friends and
who just the people who didn't want to
understand what we were doing I agree
it's yeah that's
they didn't want us to tell them no and
then at the same time you know we're
like why don't you get it asked then
don't give your advice yeah I remember
you saying that reason is it'll just
frustrate the card out of your
absolutely stupid yeah yeah and they
didn't ask way to go you guys so great
so great well we're gonna give you a
signed copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired book because that's the next
thing you do is you go and finish
building wealth now that your debt free
and live like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
I'm very proud of its honor to meet you
same day well done and mr. Carter's here
to help us scream good-looking young
guys are not gonna hear me Dave because
my husband will scream thank you alright
it's Andrew Sarah and Carter Austin
Texas area one hundred and fifty three
thousand dollars paid off in forty two
months making eighty five to one eighty
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
well done yeah I think they heard that
back in Texas good job guys
that's awesome that's how you do it you
know if you want to change your life if
you want to lose weight if you want to
get out of debt if you want to make your
marriage better if you want to get a
four-year degree you know how you do it
you have to get sick and tired of being
sick and tired you have to get disgusted
with the status quo you have to have
that moment where you finally say that's
it
I've at Les Brown who says when you
finally say the I've had it word that's
when you decide that's when you commit
that's when everything changes I've had
it I'm not living like this
any more when you have that moment
that's when it changes
and you know no one can have that moment
for you I can't do it for you I can just
tell you there's a high correlation
between people who finally say I've had
it and those that change their lives I
got a friend that's lost 40 pounds and
you know what he did he said I said I've
had it I'm sick of being fat sick of
being fat I've had it and and you know
they just that's it and you know so he
starts to doing the stuff we all know
you have to do right yeah this is not
rocket science people and yet most
people live mediocre lives because they
don't they're not intentional about the
steps they take in their lives
that's not you that changes today ready
set go
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in economy
you